the announcement by Ukraine's President
Vladimir zalinski ends weeks of
speculation about the apparent deepening
Rift with his top Soldier General valer
alusi in an attempt to limit the damage
both men have been presenting this as an
amicable separation and a long needed
reset of military
strategy today I decided to renew the
leadership of the Armed Forces of
Ukraine it's not about surnames and even
less about politics this is about the
system of our army and management and
the Armed
Forces as head of the Armed Forces
credited with thwarting Russia's
full-scale Invasion two years ago zi
established himself as a highly
influential figure nationally and
extremely popular with his soldiers but
he'd also been blamed for recent
setbacks most notably the failed counter
offensive that began last summer with
talk of disagreements between himself
from president zinski on how to conduct
the war there was also a widely rumored
Fallout between the two men over
legislation to mobilize hundreds of
thousands of more troops needed on the
front
lines as for the local draft officers as
of now Frankly Speaking I am not
currently satisfied with the work of the
draft officers if I were satisfied with
their work we would not discuss this
bill right now this rift at the very top
of the government and milit hierarchies
comes at a difficult time for Ukraine
with fighting seemingly at a stalemate
billions of dollars in military aid held
up in the US and with Russian forces
pushing hard for a significant win on
the Eastern Front ahead of the second
anniversary of its fullscale War Rob
McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer